una ciudad fantasma despojada de
habitantes y rodeada de fuego de
artillería
este edificio ha sido atacado por un
cohete que todavía no ha explotado la
mayoría de evacuados han encontrado
refugio a 50 kilómetros en martín y uno
de los espacios seguros es esta iglesia
evangélica
[Música]
esta es la habitación para los menores
entre los refugiados varios niños que
pasaron la noche escondiéndose de los
bombardeos
estaba cerrando mi puerta para irme del
pueblo cuando unos diez metros explotó
una bomba movi el coche pero los niños
estaban dentro cuando dispararon parecía
el infierno y tendrá efectos a largo
plazo en la salud mental de nuestros
niños
los menores pasaron cuatro horas
atrapados bajo tierra uno de ellos tiene
graves problemas de salud
no puede huir no puede hablar no duerme
por la noche sobrevive gracias a la
medicación en su familia ha regresado al
pueblo para alimentar al ganado
es el primo de estas dos niñas que
todavía no saben que su padre soldado ha
desaparecido enfermo dejando a su
familia sumida en la incertidumbre
los soldados me dijeron que estaba
herido perdón que estaba muerto pero
todavía no está en la lista de soldados
fallecidos así que no sabemos qué hacer
a quién contactar
el padre del soldado pidió ayuda a la
comunidad internacional
se acuerda durante el conflicto de 2020
solo naciones unidas- pudo detener esto
pueden pararlo ahora si ellos no lo
hacen quién lo hará
ni siquiera el ejército puede dar a esta
familia respuestas claras embarazada de
ocho meses su mujer no encuentra las
palabras
me siento fatal todavía no se lo he
dicho a mis hijos
un centenar de soldados armenios han
perdido la vida desde que se reanudó la
ofensiva de azerbaiyán según las
autoridades de ereván